all right can chris solve today's trivia
question to determine first pick in the
goats in a bad way draft who has
the most receiving touchdowns
10 in all since week 5 of last season
wow most receiving touchdowns
since week five of last season and it's
very relevant right now i heard like
matt casey talk about before so i'm
trying to just all right i think he's
probably gonna be funny and go devonte
adams because i left him off my top 10
wide receiver list
this is a question from
nicole on the staff i don't know what
the motivation was but i agree with it
whatever it was because it stumped you
darius slayton
with ten touchdowns has the most in the
nfl since week five of last season
nicole's a giants fan so i should have
if you told me she asked the question i
would have known that but darius slayton
very under the radar has a chance to be
a really special receiver as you saw
last night a little bit
would you rather have darius sleight
nerdo beckham jr right now well i'd
rather have odell right now you're still
i'd still rather vote but him junior uh
you know that yes i'm not right i'm
telling you yeah we got to do goats in a
bad way and there may be some discussion
of odo beckham jr or other browns coming
up but
but
uh
i think the trade for otto beckham jr is
what popped the bubble for the browns i
think everything was going okay and i
still don't know freddie kitchens would
have been the answer but i think
introducing that dynamic that
personality into that locker room at
that time is the thing that has thrown
the organization into a tizzy from which
it is still not recovered and they
better recover quickly because they got
the bengals coming on thursday night
chris yeah well it wasn't a good look
the other day i know that i mean baker
didn't look good the offense didn't look
good they didn't run the ball all that
effectively odell didn't catch the ball
he had a few drops uh i mean they looked
like they took a step back so we'll see
where they go they got to build on
something and start showing a little
something for the talent they got on
that roster
and they stepped into the meat grinder
that is the baltimore ravens so it again
could be the toughest game they have all
year all we know is with one loss their
worst or their best possible record
could be 15 and one which wouldn't be
all that bad but i wouldn't bet on it
all right i look bless his heart i gotta
go with the andre swift he's the go to
the week it's his first game in the nfl
but you got a touchdown pass in your
hands it would have delivered the
victory after your team blew a lead it
never should have come to that but
that's a catch you got to make and i
think he knows that's a catch you got to
make and i feel bad making him the
number one go to the week but it's the
most obvious
outcome determinative
if you catch it you win you drop it you
lose it's that simple it's that binary
it's that linear and i feel bad doing it
but it's got to be done somebody's got
to say it somebody's got to do it he
knows it yeah the question is what will
he do going forward to build on it yeah
that's right i mean we expect you know
big things from this player and deandre
smith very talented coming out of
georgia
man that's rough and your first game
ever and you know probably doing
something that he's not really all that
accustomed to doing either again georgia
didn't have him running out of the
backfield running corner routes and
things like that uh but nonetheless
should have caught the ball and hey you
could as much as we make him to go we
could easily say matthew stafford
deserves to be a go for the stupid
interception he threw the drive before
that to let the bears go ahead you know
so that that there there's many to go
around in that game all right well i
guess i'm going to pick the goat for the
goat draft i'm going to pick the great
ghost or the bad guy
okay
well
i i i know you've been waiting you've
been waiting no i haven't how long
you've been in the media how long have
you been in the meeting now
five six seven years however long it is
that's how long you've been waiting to
do this to to make clear to everyone
that you you don't like tom brady that's
right i don't like him screw that guy
okay either way it's not true i like tom
brady but nobody will ever believe me
because i talk realistic about him but
either way all right here we go
yes it was underwhelming you know that
and your head coach tells you you make
two big plays and it sets up the other
team for 14 points in your debut game
you know against what's supposed to look
like the greatest show on turf from
everybody that's you know you've talked
to following football
okay yes
you know you can look at that game and
seriously point at it and go
a big part of the reason they lost that
game was because tom brady did jameis
winston type things do i expect that to
continue to happen absolutely not but as
far as week one was concerned
yeah i think that was i think it's
justified i'm not trying to be a jerk or
pick on tom brady or anything like that
and look he's on my list too so all
right you're not out of line and it is
great to make the goat one of the goats
in a bad way of the week i have a
feeling it's not going to happen often
this year all right hey
i i gave you a chance to take him
i passed on him to start i thought about
taking him here ago
jimmy g it's got to be jimmy g it's got
to be i watched that game yesterday and
and look
i i told shireen this last night on
pftpm
i would take kyler murray over jimmy
garoppolo 100 out of 100 times without
hesitation kyler murray is already a
better quarterback noticeably yes than
jimmy garoppolo garoppolo was out of
sorts the balls he completed weren't
weren't as accurate as they could have
been he threw the hospital ball to
to george and chris we talked yesterday
about the end of the game and and the
ball that was essentially the dad
throwing the candy bar to the two kids
right he's like have fun go get it right
that was the patrick peterson play but
then the play after that the five yard
out another one just like that well no
there was there was the it was one it
was the third down play garoppolo came
out of the pocket and rolled to the
right oh and there were two guys in the
end zone and it was the same thing no
there it is here's the candy bar and
they're both there and what what it's
like what the hell is this when you have
that many what the hell is this moments
you're not going to be kyle shanahan's
quarterback for very long no i agreed i
mean it's this is a high octane
offense potentially we know that and
it's a high octane offensive play caller
so it was not a good start for jimmy
garoppolo and i think you know again
what you said yeah let alone the
mistakes
some of the good wasn't as good as it
should have been you there was
completions in yards left on the field
you're right because balls are
inaccurate ball's behind guy's gonna go
to the ground and you go man if he
throws that accurate that guy's gonna
run for another 10 yards but he doesn't
get to do that so uh not a good look for
him in week one certainly not all right
i'm going to minnesota i'm going to gary
kubiak that's where i'm going to go
you can't have five passes at the end of
the first half in the nfl football game
in 2020. maybe 1920 that's acceptable
2020 not acceptable gotta do something
hurry up offense we gotta change the
tempo gotta do something to get the team
started at some point and to me that was
one of the more underwhelming things i
saw this weekend uh just an unacceptable
stat line and again not that this is
like the greatest show on turf but
there's enough talent there in minnesota
for them to
have more of an offensive output than
they did in that game and especially in
that first half
yeah i agree with you and i'll tell you
what i was thinking about somebody from
the defensive side of the ball and my
pick would have been dom capers because
if anybody in that organization knows
what makes aaron rodgers tick it's the
guy who was the defensive coordinator of
the packers during aaron rodgers tenure
who's been there at practice who if he
ever had any inside information or
insights on how to confuse and confound
aaron rodgers
now's the time to use them this is your
chance they fired you this is every
motivation every opportunity every
reason for dom capers to go to mike
zimmer and say this is exactly what we
need to do to confuse this guy this is
how you beat him this is how you shut
him down and he has one of the best
games of his career so i would pick dom
capers but i'm not picking dom capers
i'm picking randy bullock the bengals
kicker
um for two reasons first of all he badly
misses a chip shop field goal that would
have sent joe burrow's debut into
overtime yeah and secondly he appeared
on the injury report yesterday not with
a calf injury but with calves plural
that is the rodney dangerfield oh my arm
is broken next level it's not just one
calf it's both
i don't even know what to say
they should have just put they should
have put pride hurt
both of them
badly uh but yeah that was i mean
unbelievable you're sitting there going
wow joe burrow hasn't been perfect but
here he is cool calm smooth as hell on
this last drive and going to put them in
position to go in overtime and who knows
what happens and just an absolute chip
shot uh that was missed badly all right
i don't know where i want to go here i
think i gotta go to philip rivers i
think that's where i'm gonna go just
because that game
as we talked about a little earlier the
cults
dominated the football game in a lot of
ways and never punted did a lot of great
things
you know i'm still not going to give up
on them after week one but rivers with
those two interceptions
that let jacksonville in the game that's
all there is to say about it they were
controlling the game he did that we've
seen that too much and that cost them
the football game yeah with a few other
mistakes by the team all in all but he
started it and that's unfortunate
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports